let's begin with the biggest game of the
day
and i'm extra happy about this one
because i saw it coming although i was
nervous about it for most of the game i
thought the steelers would go to
baltimore and win there's something
about this steelers game
and and big picture let's start it at 10
000 feet
as the cool kids like to say and then
work our way down
what's your biggest takeaway from the
outcome of the game
my biggest takeaway from the outcome
outcome of the game is
i mean if if lamar jackson is
not careless with the football the
ravens are going to win the game easily
i mean that would be my biggest takeaway
you know
the game itself was controlled by
baltimore
you know to me again and i know we
haven't you know we're watching a lot of
games and doing all that
but i thought they were clearly the
better football team on the field
now i'm not trying to take anything away
from pittsburgh or anything like that
i'm giving them credit i know blitzburg
they're
that's what they do they cause turnovers
do those type of things to help their
football team
but i still think like the big questions
with baltimore
are there too you know within that like
yeah i think baltimore was a better team
yeah i think lamar jackson really hand
gift rapted
wrapped a few uh you know turnovers and
points for them
all together and we're still gonna have
questions about lamar
when they have to pass and you know it's
a passing down
can he overcome those situations and i
think that's still a real question
well and and one of the one of the
questions i have
big picture as it relates to the ravens
and lamar jackson you know we've heard
complaints about teams like the browns
that can't beat good
teams the ravens for as good as they are
against the above average to the average
to the bad team right you rarely see
them stub their toe in a game they
should win and lamar jackson's regular
season record is
phenomenal but he's now oh and three
against the chiefs which he has called
the team's kryptonite right he's one and
one against the steelers and the win
last year has a big ben sized asterisk
next to it because roethlisberger wasn't
there
and they barely want it in overtime if
marlon humphrey doesn't punch the ball
out of juju smith schuster and the ball
stay in bounds
the ravens may have lost that game look
at these numbers from two appearances
with
lamar jackson against pittsburgh and i'm
glad we started banging this drum last
week because it ended up being somewhat
prescient
saks five the last time four yesterday
turnovers three in week five of the 2019
season
four yesterday that's not good and so if
the chiefs are the kryptonite i i don't
know
i mentioned this last night i don't know
the
the superman trivia enough to figure out
what the steelers are
but there's got to be something else
that bugs superman
beyond kryptonite and the steelers are
it yeah well they got a lot of the
pieces to
yeah bother superman in this case
certainly i mean i think you know
hey their front seven the way they fly
around
you know that that is always gonna cause
problems for anybody let alone a guy
like lamar jackson who yes
is gonna tote the line of you know
holding the football or
i might make a cut back here even though
i see there's defenders coming and it
could be dangerous but i'm gonna go for
it and try to cut
reverse field here 20 yards whatever
that is the steelers are big they're
physical
and they do rely on this style of
football definitely but when you talk
about lamar jackson
pick six to start the game you know then
the interception to start the second
half which
leads to jump starting the steelers
offense who could do
nothing at that point like absolutely
nothing
everybody go look at the stats of the
first half of the raven steelers game
the game is dominated by the ravens then
those so there's two interceptions then
the fumble
as they're down in the red area right
dancing around the 10-yard line or so
mike
the game's 7-7 they turn the ball over
they leave seven points on the board or
at least three points on the board right
there i mean they stop pittsburgh
pittsburgh punts it back they drive
right down
pittsburgh never really stopped
baltimore all day long
but they have play makers and that's why
you signed big money playmakers because
they make big plays and big moments and
we saw that yesterday from them yeah if
you told me before the game the ravens
would have 265 rushing yards i would
assume the ravens would write a game
31-10 or something like that but that
wasn't the case
let's hear from lamar jackson on his
mistakes and from mike tomlin the
steelers coach on the fact that the
steelers don't fear
the 2019 mvp
the turnovers i feel is the reason why
we lost the game i put that on me
the start of the game the first drive of
pick six uh
then we drive to the red zone a fumble
uh i gotta get the ball i could because
we know they're dominant up front
uh and then the pick um off the off the
player from the flat to throwing at the
mark got to clean those up and i feel we
won that game so
that's all to it you don't expect um
lamar jackson to
make those kind of interceptions how big
was that to change the momentum
you know um you know we got respect for
him but we don't fear him
um and and so you know we're not
surprised by anything that transpires
hey mike tom no no no
but but that's the thing if you are in
awe of a guy you've already lost
they are not in awe of lamar jackson and
and the other thing is they are not
afraid to hit a quarterback who becomes
a running back right i asked mika
fitzpatrick about that after the game it
comes from the coaching staff
and and this is in an era where we see
defensive players get
hesitant when the quarterback becomes a
running back and for good reason because
the flag pops up in the pocket for the
officials
when you hit a quarterback the same way
you'd hit a running back lamar jackson
drew a foul yesterday
at the sideline that if it was a running
back if it was mark ingram jk dobbins
gus edwards that flag's not coming out
you're right
it came out because it came out because
it was lamar jackson but the steelers
don't care
they'd rather and this is a more artful
way to make the point that i made it
back in january
and pissed off all the chiefs fans the
steelers would rather just go play
football and if it means that that the
official may throw a flag because it's a
quarterback and not a running back they
don't care
right if he becomes a runner we're going
to go tackle him and we're going to hit
him and we're going to make him think
twice about running again now mega
fitzpatrick said
other quarterbacks they start to slide
more quickly they start peeking around
lamar jackson isn't affected by it but
you have to wonder whether or not
getting hit and getting rattled and
always being concerned about that
steelers defense at some point
contributes to the mistakes he made yeah
no
i mean yes it does and you know again
that that
goes into hey it's baltimore it's lamar
jackson
you heard him referred to you know down
in the red zone
i can't hold the ball like that we know
they got a dominant pass front
you know this to what you said mike you
know the steelers not being afraid or
intimidated
you know that that is certainly an
aspect most teams who play baltimore
lose the fear intimidation factor and
the lamar jackson
off factor you know within the first few
drives of the game the first few times
he goes zoom zoom zoom and up the middle
and all around the edge and throws a
pass they're like oh my gosh baltimore's
amazing
we can't beat them pittsburgh yeah
they're not gonna get that and
especially not
in that type of game i mean first off
with that game right there
there's more alphas you know badass
mofos okay sorry for my language there
on a monday morning right i just wanted
to tote the line a little bit
but more in this game than you'll find
any other game all year as far as
big physical people and you have to
adjust your game
when you play in games like that to
where even a guy like lamar jackson is
gifted as you are
right mike he's got to reign it in a
little bit to just go
wait this is a different beast i'm
playing this week
this is not you know the cleveland
browns or some of these other teams
where i can just run circles around
their linebackers and their safeties you
hold the ball you make a mistake against
the steelers t.j watt
dupree to it they're coming and they're
going to force an issue and
i think lamar maybe he can build on that
aspect next time around
to just have a feel for the intensity
speed of their defense
to where he can maybe be better but he
certainly was the big issue yesterday
and you know it still came down to the
last play of the game right
and if if lamar jackson
makes a better decision with the
football maybe
gets minka fitzpatrick to commit the way
that fitzpatrick
thought that jackson was going to go
fitzpatrick told me after the game that
when they broke the huddle and he saw to
his left
marquis brown and mark andrews he
thought it was going to come to andrews
up the slot
and lamar jackson looked that way and
fitzpatrick was watching that way but
then when it
pivoted back to the other side that's
when fit patrick broke and
broke up the pass intended for willie
snead and john harbaugh
i think he was i think he was suggesting
not necessarily interference with blow
to the head of a defenseless receiver
right
because even if you don't go helmet to
helmet you still can't
strike a receiver in the head or neck
area with your forearm with your hand
right your shoulder with
anything while he's in the defenseless
posture
that flag wasn't coming out in that spot
not on that play it wasn't egregious it
would have to be
you flatten the guy you you jack tatum
the guy
with your with your elbow i mean you
just you do a clothesline or something
like that before that flag's coming out
definitely uh yeah but it was a great
play he he touched the ball first you
know
that's what we've lost track of that
rule in the as far as
ball down still defenseless he's still
defensive if you touch the ball first
okay well he's talking about i'm not
talking about interference i'm talking
about defenseless i know but for getting
hit
the guy is not he's making zero play to
hit the guy
he actually is going to play the ball
completely
and he touches the ball before the
offensive guy does
so that right yeah that you know to me i
i mean i'm just i'm trying to
accentuate the point a little bit to
where yeah i don't think john harbaugh
can ask for that call there like you're
saying it wasn't a launch it wasn't
somebody trying to hit
somebody it was truly two people trying
to play the ball
but we've seen questionable calls you're
right i know in an effort
to protect players but usually it
involves a helmet of a defense a
defensive player
not the hands and you're right
fitzpatrick did touch the ball first
there was no question about pass
interference though it wasn't in part
because he touched the ball first this
is about
being struck in the head and it wasn't
nearly severe enough to get that flag so
the steelers win and and
look the steelers even though they're
perfect in the win loss column it really
was far from perfect we mentioned
yeah 265 rushing yards time of
possession out of whack
and the ravens did outplay them i don't
know
how you feel about this look at this 221
total yards
for the steelers 457 for the ravens
48 rushing yards for the st if if you
show me that
without showing me the final score i say
as i said earlier 3110 right right right
that that's what's amazing to me that
the steelers found a way to win this
game but you know what that's what great
teams do that's what teams do when
they're having a special season they
find a way
in the one stat that matters all the
rest of it doesn't matter
points scored versus points allowed is
all that matters
and that's their focal point chris no
you're right and that's why
they are masters at finding playmakers
on a full on a defense offense whatever
that may be
hey it's a tough game the scheme's not
going to always deliver
you know at some point you need some
guys that can make some plays and some
big moments that can you know
surpass what the scheme has to deliver
for you
and you can make the plays and you know
you bring up that stat sheet again too
kristin if you don't mind in the back
there
you know another thing too though i
think is we got to stop this because
this is
this is a part of football if you see
the the total yards there
you know we saw pittsburgh 221 yards
look at the nine penalties for 110 yards
that
i mean to me that should go almost onto
the total yards of pittsburgh too big
ben did a great job of taking some shots
down
field to create some pass interference
calls which were also part of those
you know yards as far as helping the
steelers out but mike i ask you this
all right going forward right because
this was a great game it was really
close
there's two ways to look at this you
know one you could be baltimore and go
okay we we messed this up right we out
played them
and we made turnovers we won't do that
next time we're going to beat their butt
pittsburgh can also look at it and go
we didn't play good and we kind of
figured it out in the second half
especially offensively because once they
kind of got jump started all of a sudden
big ben and them they figured out how
they wanted to attack baltimore
and who like who do you think has the
advantage going next next time around
where pittsburgh can go yeah we got
outplayed but we still
won and we can play better who do you
think has the edge in that you know as
far as that
psychological aspect there well
you know it's a great question and i'm
not i'm not punting on it but
the thing we have to keep in mind both
teams need to forget about it
for now especially the ravens chris
because they got
the colts they got the patriots they got
the titans before the game on
thanksgiving night in pittsburgh which
you'll see on nbc i mean think about
that
they gotta play the titans the team that
beat them in the playoffs last year on
sunday yes and then thursday night of
that week by the pittsburgh steelers
so they they should not think about the
steelers at all until
after that titans game ends they they
already know what to do i think if
you're the ravens your mindset is let's
just go do what we did yeah
and and surely all those breaks won't go
their way and surely we'll have an
officiating crew that won't give 110
yards to the steelers
and if we just go play the way we played
except for the turnovers if we just go
do what we did
it'll work out this time yeah it just
was a fluke that we lost the last time
and they're gonna be desperate i mean
look now the steelers could all of a
sudden start losing game after game
after game but as of right now they've
got a two-game lead
plus they hold the tiebreaker if they
would end up winning the game on
thanksgiving night
that that is essentially four games
well yeah that the ravens otherwise have
to make up because you have to catch
them and then pass them in the standings
because they'll hold the tiebreaker yeah
and to mike to your point just to you
know bring it up i mean
pittsburgh you talk about the ravens
next three games pittsburgh's got
the cowboys the bengals and the jaguars
before they play the ravens
i mean they legitimately on thanksgiving
night unless they just mess it up one of
these next three weeks and and really
joe burrow and the bangles is going to
be the toughest part of that three
three week match up steelers are going
to go into thanksgiving night
really with a great chance to be 10-0 i
mean how awesome is that going to be
that we might have a chance to watch the
steelers ravens thanksgiving night
really important football game steelers
undefeated against their rivals uh man i
i hope it actually plays out that way
i'm hoping for that and
let me say this if this was the patriots
in any year of the past 15
right yeah with that remaining schedule
right we'd be talking about him going
undefeated you're right he's going to
talk about the steelers going undefeated
but if it was the patriots you're right
right look at that schedule pull it up
again
other than the ravens game thanksgiving
night which is hardly an easy one
there is no game on there that screams
out lost now the bills game
boy the best two games left for the
steelers on nbc
on sunday night football against the
bills and thanksgiving night against the
ravens right
but but those are the only ones that
make you pause
and based upon what we've seen the first
eight weeks of the season you're not
gonna pause for long you're gonna say
yeah it's gonna be a tough game they'll
find a way to win it because
once you do that eight times people
start believing
yeah they kind of know how to figure out
how to win these games and i think
part of this has its roots in what
happened last year when you don't have
your starting quarterback
and you still have that mentality of
fight and scratch and claw
and never give up yeah fight and scratch
and claw and never give up
and then you get ben roethlisberger back
that's right damn that makes all the
difference in the world
big ben big ben big ben
big ben we do got to give him some props
before we move on to the next game just
because
again like lamar who played awesome but
you know played by like his you know
pants were on fire
and it cost him with four turnovers big
ben did a great job of
wait let me let the game come to me here
let i'm not going to mess it up he
understood what the rivalry is all about
and how to play this football team
and that yeah it might not look pretty
but when we have our moment or when i
have to we'll step on the gas
and you know their defense of course
delivered for them
but that jumpstart at the start of the
second half
you know they really figured out how
they wanted to kind of short
passing game oh it's one-on-one we'll
take our shot downfield
they found their mojo there a little in
the second half too to where
you know big ben the next time he plays
the ravens i think he's going to feel a
lot better about it to where their
offense can go into that matchup going
wait i think we know how to attack them
a little bit better we know what to do
we
we know the feel the size what
everything about them too
to where hey i got to give big ben
credit year off from football
he's gotten better every week and even
though yesterday wasn't beautiful
it was still really good and he didn't
mess the game up which is what most
quarterbacks do against the ravens
and i think there's a lot to be said
about that there was a minor elbow scare
for ben yesterday he went down kind of
awkwardly and they were
checking it out but everything was fine
and notre dame receiver
chase claypool is being spoiled as a
rookie in the nfl he tweeted
losing never heard about that's great
hey it's something to come to the nfl
and end up 7-0 and hey how about this
avery williamson the jets linebacker
traded to the steelers to go from 0-8
to 7-0 are you kidding me yeah
when did that happen oh last thing that
happened last night what were you doing
watching football i don't know i did not
know you got to crack
crack open twitter once in a while avery
williamson traded that's a good
trade for the steelers that really is
he's still a good player
and yeah that gives him another stud
inside and that 3-4 defense wow that's
that was really good job hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports